let's go right at it eat this money this
is a meme that has become very popular
especially in the etherium defy
community and really the way that I've
analyzed this or kind of you know
evaluated it is basically what eath is
money is saying is ethers good money
right because if we don't say 'if is
good money then I could say rocks or
money you know Cheetos or money etc but
ethers good money is really going at
this idea of kind of what you talked
about like collateral right and in these
defy systems we're seeing a thirst for
certain mechanisms or you know products
and features etc let's just start with
agree or disagree eath is money well I
would say I think the sort of meme on
Twitter is that eath would like to be
money I don't think anything in crypto
is money yet I don't think bitcoin is
money and in fact I think maker Dow died
the stable coin is probably the closest
thing to money and anything in crypto
but mark I would think but in the market
would disagree with that
meaning that bit quote from a
transaction standpoint that the on chain
adjusted transaction volume of Bitcoin
last year was just under a trillion
dollars right time and so maker I don't
know what dice pacifically is it it's
not zero it's definitely popular like
sixty percent I think of the value
locked and defy is is die and so that's
a real amount right that that's not you
know anything to kind of thumb your nose
in it but at the same time we're talking
about I think there's a billion dollars
locked in defy right so let's call it
somewhere in the hundreds of millions of
dollars versus hundreds of billions of
dollars for Bitcoin I don't think
anything's even close to Bitcoin but I
will say that I've got a strong opinion
that's loosely held so hopefully for
your sake you can convince me
differently but that's just kind of the
way I think about it it's like the
market almost doesn't care about our
opinions and if you look at the data the
markets determined Bitcoin to be more of
money than anything else what do you
think about that agree disagree well I
think you know they're all striving to
me mana
Terry assets mm-hmm right and so the
cryptocurrencies not not anything else
just the ones that want to be currencies
that's what they're striving to be
pretty much all of them I would I think
everything in crypto is locked in a
battle to be a monetary asset with the
exception of maybe some of these like
buy and burn sort of dividend kind of
tokens like maker Dow it's that maker
has a token that basically a cruise
value from died going up it's called MKR
and they have died so maybe MKR isn't
trying to be money but dies trying to be
money Ethan's try and be money Tron is
trying to be money and they're all in
aspect Ron everything I got a shot you
know do you think your shot everyone's
shooting beam I mean that's the
innovation right like this is the cool
thing about crypto which is why it's so
exciting you know we came from the
internet my partner to he's a very
famous VC in China who was one of the
first VCS in the internet the thing
that's exciting about about crypto is
that it's permissionless innovation and
and he used to be like no one could
create their own TV network that was
just unbelievably like nobody thought
that was possible look at us now today
right look ma we did it it used to be
you think nobody could create your own
money since Ain it's the province of 200
governments even really more like 20 now
anyone can create their own money good
luck
it's not that easy but certainly East is
trying to be money Bitcoin is trying to
be money they're still very far away
from it I think the the market cap is
just a sign that like it's the most
valued digital asset right but an asset
is different than money I mean it's not
used every day as a means of exchange
and so forth nothing really is we
shouldn't kid ourselves about that if
anything tether is probably the most
used as a medium of exchange asset in
all of crypto I don't know if it's a
strong store value as Bitcoin the amount
of turnover and tether is is incredibly
high but like you know so from the from
the way economists think about it three
things of uh you know aspects of money
and one sense bitcoin is much higher as
a store value in another sense dyeing
tether actually might be higher as a
medium of exchange today so my big
argument this week was that eath is no
different than a fiat currency now
wow that was controversial but and
that's fine right I have no problem
having different thoughts than people
but one thing to clarify here is I'm
gonna guess 50% of people who were
yelling and screaming on the internet
didn't read the article which is like a
problem in society in general that's not
a crypto thing that's just like politics
social you know culture or always gossip
but what I said in the article was the
monetary policy of eath makes it no
different than a fiat currency right
meaning that there's essentially groups
of people who make decisions on the
monetary policy of the asset
periodically now what I will say is a
positive for the eath is money crowd is
that every time that they have made the
decision they have made it in what many
people would consider the quote unquote
right direction right meaning that they
have decreased the supply of money and
so that is good in the sense of they're
not going the opposite direction like a
true fiat currency would but
structurally the fact that this group of
people can make that decision and it
could go up or down it's not kind of pre
programmatically decided in my opinion
makes it no different than a fiat
currency agree/disagree
think I'm an idiot yeah does he great
decide the reason we shouldn't think I
was an idiot so that's a start I read
the article - I did read it and I didn't
trash talking on Twitter yet so disagree
because I think you know certainly
bitcoin is ahead in that it has the most
decentralized and sort of stable social
consensus around its monetary policy
that's amazing that's the best thing
about Bitcoin today probably by far you
know it's not leading and like
technology or scalability or privacy but
it's got maybe arguably the most
important thing which is sort of this
inbuilt scarcity it's hard to fork that
out the problem with that though is and
it becomes a bigger problem with with
sort
new consensus protocols and so forth is
the ultimately these networks have to be
secure right and the monetary policy is
the security of the network right and
there's the biggest way that Bitcoin
could fail today is if the when the
basically Bitcoin the bitcoin is secured
by two sort of cash flows that the
security of it by mining so the first is
by block rewards and the second is by a
small fee that everyone pays to miners
when they make a transaction and a lot
of the sort of simulations today of what
happens if there's no block rewards if
it's zero and if it's all just
transaction fees is that there will be
serious security risks and it'll be much
easier to attack the network and will be
less stable so it will just just
interrupt for a second it should be
clear that's expectations or predictions
of what's gonna happen in a hundred
years 120 years right 2100 twenty or
thirty two thousand how having is going
2,140 is when the last Bitcoin will be
mined right give or take yeah but it
gets progressively I mean as you get
down to three percent two percent one
percent where are we now two and a half
or something I mean the lower it goes
the sort of exponentially more difficult
to gets and in fact we wrote my
colleagues we have like a fairly large
research arm we did an analysis of how
this relates to defy and in fact if you
have this issue where if the lending
rate if basically the the risk-free rate
of lending out Bitcoin or aetherium
becomes significantly greater than the
monument it's actually much much bigger
issue for proof of stake because there's
no you don't feel like by mining
equipment and it's just it's a decision
of whether you stake your asset or you
lend your asset out it leaves a
disastrous consequences because people
won't stake and they'll mine and they'll
and they'll lend it out and said
actually so that's not as applicable to
Bitcoin but it is applicable to theory
and any other proof of stake asset so
like I understand why if theorem is
doing this they have to understand that
and they do understand that especially
if they move to proof of stake a new
alternative
the monetary policy has to be flexible
for security reasons I mean what's gonna
happen if Bitcoin even 20 30 years from
now is like insecure and it doesn't it's
like easy to attack I will the will the
sort of social consensus of scarcity and
and the fixed monetary policy kill it I
don't know I mean that'll be a major a
major decision for the Bitcoin community
for sure so going back to the idea that
eath is money right and it's no
different than a fiat currency why do
you believe it is different than the
fiat currency right and really my
thought process was when you outline
what it how is the monetary policy
decisions and structure of a fiat
currency decided eath looks very very
similar to me yeah I think we're all on
a spectrum between with fiat currencies
gonna rent we're all creating our own
central banks here the main innovation
in crypto where anyone can create their
central bank is that you know crypto is
all about incentives so the problem of
central banking the fundamental problem
is there's too tart goals the Fed and
all feds try to hit one reduce inflation
to create a stable currency that you
know increases economic output and so
forth but to reduce unemployment and
those two things and then also the third
is that's sort of secret but is also
important and it's sort of tied to the
second is you get access to senior age
and you get to basically like you get an
unlimited amount of spending if you're
the government you could sort of print
your way to freedom at least for a few
years in the short term and these don't
really don't tell don't tell them that
they know you know they then look at
look at Trump's tweets look at how
Powell is reacting to Trump's like
Powell is much more conservative before
he became the Fed chair then after it's
sort of an F like we try to create these
mechanisms of church and state to
separate the central bank from the
government and often they work for a few
decades but no currency has remained
stable for more than a hundred years so
these basically this is an incentive
problem like these three things
conflict with each other all the time
and there's governments have every
incentive to sacrifice inflation for to
juice unemployment or to spend more
money especially in election years right
but Bitcoin and aetherium don't have
that okay there's not like concept of
unemployment rates that need to you know
if like your monetary policy goes up and
down and it's miners that get the senior
age and the miners today don't really
have much influence or say in the in the
sort of social consensus making these
monetary policies so in that sense eath
is a great improvement
really the only thing today is sort of
the only lever the decision that is
affecting their monetary policy is one
everyone wants to be lower and then two
is security and that's cool I think the
trade-off between you know we're
incentive to increase security of the
network in this cryptographic way that's
a much cooler trade-off than we're
incentivized to juice the economy
whenever is an election year that's a
still a quantum leap ahead of all other
fiat currencies yeah so just so people
understand aetherium is that obviously
the network there's ether the asset and
the monetary policy of ether is
something called a minimum issuance and
the minimum issuance is basically is it
every year how often is the decision
made I don't know okay so periodically
they basically make a decision as to the
rate of issuance that will occur until
the next decision yeah and so again kind
of a positive argument for eath is that
they have decreased that every time so
it it has acted similar to Bitcoin in
that the Bitcoin having yeah the two
fundamental issues that I have is so
fiat currencies I basically out laid
three things said there's no fixed
supply there's an inflationary supply
schedule and the monetary policy
decisions are divided or decided by a
group of people right so no fixed supply
inflationary monetary schedule and the
decision as to that rate is decided by a
group of people if you look at eath
there's no fixed supply it has an
inflationary monetary supply error
schedule and it is decided by a group of
people now when you you
that framework which is a framework that
I you know in full transparency I made
up right then you're good then you can
apply it to eath and Fiat they look
exactly the same in comparison if you
were to put Bitcoin into that you would
say that Bitcoin has a fixed supply so
it doesn't meet that first criteria now
it has a disinflationary supply schedule
meaning that there is an additional
increase in supply every year every day
etc it is programmatically declining in
time if theorem has done the exact same
thing so it's been disinflationary over
time but the difference is that Bitcoin
is programmed to continue to be
disinflationary a theory em could step
in and say hey there's security concerns
and so therefore we were actually going
to increase the rate rather than
decrease it and the third is that the
monetary policy decisions are decided by
a small group of individuals a big
difference between Bitcoin in aetherium
for example is that there is a preset
monetary policy with Bitcoin that is
programmatic and there is the
possibility that people could come
together with majority and change that
monetary policy right that's kind of
social consensus you're talking about
etc the difference is with aetherium
that is not a preset programmatic
monetary policy right and so there's
kind of these periodic decisions that
need to be made now one am i absolutely
crazy for kind of evaluating it this way
and using that framework or how do you
kind of think through that framework as
what's good what's bad and kind of what
did I miss
no I think it's good I think the the
thing you're missing a little bit is
that it's all a spectrum there are it's
like there are people at the end of
everything it's Turtles all the way down
so Bitcoin is clearly optimizing for
being as little controlled by people as
possible this is like nick szabo sort of
inventor of smart contracts is his
concept of like there's dry and like wet
code you know and and wet code and is
messy and of all people and lawyers and
so forth dry code is automated and
automation of like of decision making is
the like the bedrock of capitalism and
and our industrial engine so it's great
if you sort of automate away the
decision-making about how you change the
monetary policy if that's what you're
optimizing for if that's what you think
is the best thing that creates the best
money supply or the best store of value
I think that's possibly the case
probably but aetherium is optimizing for
other things which is that aetherium is
fast moving relatively we need to take
in a long time for each 2.0 to come but
it's fast moving it's dynamic it's more
it's like it's up the other things that
make something a good digital asset
money supply like having built-in
privacy or having scalability whether at
the layer one or layer to having
programmability like being able to allow
a decentralized financial ecosystem to
exist natively in a trustus way tied to
your currency and in your ecosystem is
very powerful
it's why you know almost all of the
collateral behind a decentralized
finances eath it's not Bitcoin yet it's
hard to do in a trust this way so those
things could make something a better
money in a way and and having your
monetary policy be decided by a group of
people and be more flexible is a
requirement if you want to optimize for
that fast you know for moving fast and
and being dynamic so it's trade-offs
right clearly the market today values
that the Bitcoin trade-off is the best
but actually like you and I we're pretty
sure like the crypto ecosystem will be
in the trillions in the next 10 -
whatever how long it takes so actually
the market is really telling us that the
real solution has not been found like
there's something missing you know like
there's a you could kind of think of it
like five trillion is like at max
capacity maybe right like when when
crypto becomes a true store of value so
Bitcoin is what 200 billion so it's like
a 4% chance or no sorry 40 yeah 40
percent chance or yeah 4 percent chance
that it becomes big that the Bitcoin of
today is the store value of the future
right that leaves a lot of United but
you could also flip that and say
bitcoins dominance is at 60 65 percent
and therefore the market determines
there's a 65% chance that bitcoin is the
winner right out of all of the options
today there's a 65% chance that Bitcoin
is the winner versus everybody else yeah
but I mean that's not the real it's like
the real market size a crypto isn't what
crypto is today it's cool like most
people still think it's gold right
okay yeah you know like 90% of the
people still think it's gold yep so it's
called 7 trillion or so yeah yeah right
so but yeah bitcoins in the lead clearly
the market determines these things so
here's my other argument is that and to
be very clear with folks I am actually a
fan of what aetherium empowers people to
do there's a lot of innovation that's
going on a lot of experimentation I
think that stuff is super important to
kind of the health of an entire
ecosystem right I am NOT and when you
ask about the maximalism I am NOT of the
belief that bitcoin is the only thing
that will ever be valuable
you know period in this entire world
mainly because I come at it from the
sense of the entire financial system is
going to get rebuilt in parallel and
therefore it would be like saying you
know the US dollar is the only thing in
the financials no there's credit there
you know there's all assets there's all
kinds of other something goes on and
they're mutually reinforcing yeah
exactly and but yeah they make the
dollar more important more valuable at
cetera right so those we have such an
advanced financial system as that base
unit of account I believe personally
that Bitcoin will be the base unit of
account of this future world there'll be
all kinds of other stuff that are built
but Bitcoin because it's that base unit
of Canada's money it ends up being the
most important right because it's kind
of the foundation but there's a bunch of
other stuff that is important that gets
built aetherium today is helping to
empower some of that to be built and
let's take the defy sector for example
when you have decentralized financial
products you need to have some form of
money right that is used in these
products the difference here is that
while some people are using eath the
most popular one in the etherium
ecosystem is not eath is actually dye
right and dye is the ERC 20 token
can you get through the whole thing but
it is fundamentally different on top of
that what you're seeing is teams work to
bring Bitcoin and its monetary policy
properties to aetherium with T BTC etc
and so again I go back like my opinion
doesn't matter your opinion does matter
frankly the market's opinion is what
matters and the market is determining
that in even just the defy world there
is something better than ethos money
right meaning dye and also there are
teams that are going out to search how
do we bring the monetary policies of
Bitcoin to this ecosystem
let's stop there for a second agree
disagree is that the right way to look
at it do you look at it a different way
just walk me through that type of the
analysis no totally it's um I would I
think dot like I would reframe dye as
money not eat this money
either's collateral eat his gold gold is
not money you know it's been many years
since anyone's used gold as money so
which is fine like the mantra don't tell
Peter Schiff but again like I like I
like the dollar
I like stability I think the greatest
crypto is about financial access really
and the Most Wanted financial asset
around the world is a dollar I mean you
have these stats where like 90% or like
some massive percent of all
hundred-dollar bills or all bills in
general is outside the US like it's just
so many percentage of countries are
fully dollarized at this point so just
bringing the dollar to the world and
bringing sort of the the feds central
banking policies to the world that I
think is where the next stage of growth
in crypto is happening absolutely you
know I don't think there's any doubt
about that in my mind so I'm sort of a
stable coin maximalist in a way when it
comes to what is money I think stable
coins will be money at least for the
next few decades or he don't point
Maximus I haven't heard that before
heard it here first
no I don't know I didn't invent it but
uh and so what that means is the asset
that collateralized is a stable coin is
gonna be very valuable to through a sort
of weird chicken-and-egg loop though and
it just like gold is very valuable
because it's the Lord you know it's one
of the largest stores in central banks
you know on balance sheets so you know
that the problem with Bitcoin and defy
is that it's not programmable so you
can't have defy on Bitcoin you just I
mean there's a few initiatives with side
chains I disagree but go ahead well I
mean we'll talk about them guys today
we'll talk I disagree but go ahead all
right sure but today it okay I mean it's
very you'd be so impossible to remake
maker Dow or compound or something on
Bitcoin natively
there's no trustless way to put Bitcoin
port Bitcoin on to the defy ecosystem
there's trusted ways to do it
there's wrapped Bitcoin where some
trusted entity right bit go has won some
other exchanges are thinking about doing
one in the next few months
they'd asically just put Bitcoin in on
chain and they show proof of reserves in
the issue like a synthetic Bitcoin
that's back but just like tether or
something really or USD see and they
have like no traction at all it's like a
couple million dollars is lokas in the
is in those assets so clearly I didn't
like a priority I wasn't sure that would
be the case it seemed like why would
people use tether why wouldn't they want
to use a centralized Wrap Bitcoin but
this is the markets decided at this
point so we're waiting for a trust this
Bitcoin that's really really hard I've
invested in a bunch of Technology
projects that will enable that like
cosmos and you have polka-dotted and
drop Billy chains you have what keep is
doing which is fantastic but there's
trade-offs
none of them are technically proven to
be technically secure yet they're costly
like they're not very capital efficient
you have to like lock up I don't know
what the latest is but you have to sort
of over collateralize and keep your with
both Bitcoin and eath so that's kind of
weird like why would you wanna if you're
using if you want to get a synthetic
Bitcoin that probably means you don't
really want to hold eath but you have to
hold both for security reasons anyway
there's a cost to that so uh clearly
today that's sort of the eath game which
is can you be collateral for a financial
system that is literally like a thousand
to ten thousand times bigger than the
base financial Cystic we know that from
just looking at the
you know the ratio goal to derivative
market cap or something like that and
that's a big play
so there's this framework that I had and
right we will I'll describe it for those
that are just listening yeah you go home
so basically on the left side you have
Bitcoin on the right side you have a
theorem right and around both Bitcoin
and a theorem is the infrastructure for
those ecosystems and so the way I think
about it is Bitcoin is sound money right
in the principles that are around that
but all of the infrastructure
historically has been centralized
infrastructure so this is when you see
the the coin basis the block flies etc
of the world right so kind of sound
money surrounded by centralized
infrastructure when you go to the
etherium side what you get is
decentralized infrastructure with an
asset that has is unproven to be sound
money today right so kind of think of I
think the ideal world here is how do we
have sound money with decentralized
infrastructure right and so you had
these two different worlds each piece
has a part of that like utopia and we've
got to bring them together now that
brings the debate of do you bring
Bitcoin to a theory on which you kind of
just described with tea BTC etc and
these wrapped etc or can you actually
bring decentralized infrastructure to
Bitcoin right I can't yet announce the
name of the company but I'm sure you've
actually seen the company we invested in
a business that is essentially going to
bring the lending capabilities of defy
to Bitcoin right there's other teams
that are working on other aspects of it
do you think that the obstacles today to
having sound money in Bitcoin with truly
decentralized infrastructure around it
or those technical challenges that can't
be solved are those what I call time and
attention meaning that we have had
enough teams working on them yet just
hasn't that for a long enough to
actually get these solutions or is there
something else that has prevented us
from having that kind of full stack
integration with sound money and
decentralized infrastructure yeah I mean
this is a
this is like the trillion dollar
question this is also the thing that
makes most maxima that's very
uncomfortable to talk about which is
bitcoin is not innovated in a decade and
is that bad thing depends what your
perspective is it's certainly a bad
thing for developers and for app makers
like imagine if I mean developing in the
1980s was way harder than being a
developer now the languages were way
more difficult to learn they were like
assembly code the developer toolkit was
way more difficult it was so imaginably
more to like more difficult to create
software and product you know software
products in the early days of the the
internet when there was less tooling and
libraries and so forth and that's where
we are with Bitcoin and we haven't moved
so that's way easier to do it on
aetherium
it will always be continually
continuously way easier and in fact the
spread will probably increase so you you
kind of have to like I mean yes it's
technically possible I think to do
scalability and to create a pretty good
okay programming environment that can
maybe do like lending in Bitcoin maybe
you know the project you've backed is
the one that's gonna crack it but eath
is flexible it's moving so it's always
getting better and better it's creating
JavaScript when you know Bitcoin is
still trying to get I don't what's that
old it but here you pull out C sharp but
I think this is one of the key things
right is and this is where the Bitcoin
crowd heavily heavily disagrees with
kind of the etherium crowd I think the
Bitcoin crowd would argue all of that
development and speed and
experimentation etc are actually flaws
not advantages around one specific
perspective
money you get one shot and so on a
spectrum between like what I call like
sexy innovation etc and confidence level
of sustainable store value medium of
exchange on that spectrum Bitcoin is is
far to the confidence side as you can
get so it's very slow it's very
intentional it's very much thinking
through we have two hundred billion
dollars give or take in this asset we
can't [ __ ] this up all of the innovation
experimentation etc that's all great but
it can't happen at the expense of
screwing up that core base unit of
account now I think aetherium what ends
up happening is the speed the innovation
etc that crowd actually looks at that as
an advantage right so they say look
you've got to move you got to innovate
you got to do all this kind of stuff
they're optimizing for two different
things
and I think what ends up happening is if
you wanted to compare eath is money to
Bitcoin is money right I think most
people would argue the Bitcoin argument
in that specific perspective is probably
much stronger than the eath one now when
you go to the infrastructure side the
innovation the sexiness all the shiny
stuff etc the speed innovation you know
experimentation all that is a much
better way to look at infrastructure
right the natural base unit of account
and so that's where I actually think it
makes sense to me at least and again I'm
hyper bias in all of this that the
developers would run into a theorem
where there was the possibility and
empowerment to do all that innovation
around infrastructure etc leave Bitcoin
to be built slow methodically
intentionally etc how it's been built
and then eventually you'll see those
developers migrate over and build that
same infrastructure that they did all
the testing and experimentation in
aetherium to build that around what ends
up being the sound money it's almost
like the sound money is a magnet for the
infrastructure but all of the
experimentation is empowered on
aetherium just eventually like the
things that work come to Bitcoin yeah
and I know all this is hyper hyper hyper
controversial people will literally be
freaking out that saying I'm an idiot
etc well that's just my person
I mean these are complex systems and
we're sort of like you've made like six
assumptions you know don't know it'll
take a few years to figure out like
technical risk what but yeah look I
think I think it's possible but clearly
today you know the other story let alone
Bitcoin defy hasn't moved to any other
ecosystem it hasn't moved to EOS it
hasn't moved for tezo's or a legrand or
anything like that
Ethan's just controlling the narrative
and controlling the like almost every
good defy project we back good team or
even team that we look at is building on
a theorem it'd be sort of nonsensical to
not at this point in time from a
business perspective so you have network
effects there so you have to think are
the network effects and developer
community and so forth strong enough
that you can sort of bootstrap eath into
a stable store of value stable is a
rough word and all crypto so you're
talking about almost like inversing it
whereas the Bitcoin argument would be
you start with sound money then you
build all the infrastructure the
derivatives well you have to you start
with sound money but your infrastructure
is always going to be significantly
worse I mean at least ten years behind
maybe more but but it's ten years behind
there are five forty five sort of five
what are though here's the difference
though the infrastructure around Bitcoin
is 1,000 times minimum more popular and
more robust than eath the difference is
that the eath infrastructure is
decentralized like if you compare
decentralized infrastructure underneath
to decentralized infrastructure on
Bitcoin you're correct if you compare
just infrastructure Bitcoin has a head
start and won't get caught right because
all of the etherium infrastructure of
the etherium specific infrastructure is
specifically going after this D
decentralized opportunity but like
coinbase yeah is originally Bitcoin
infrastructure right bit go is Bitcoin
info structure but right but by the way
they've been co-opted but I mean they
expand yeah absolutely I mean the egos
in exchanges custodians market
infrastructure on all strands that's
there's almost none of those that are
just for Bitcoin yet now Bitcoin has
much more liquidity of course much more
pairs but actually eath is doing a
pretty good job even X we're not at zero
for your job yeah yeah I'm
again I'm not a Maximus in the sense of
like there's just one app oh and the
original companies that were only
Bitcoin they've lost in the market coin
I mean coinbase got a lot of flack for
when it launched a bunch of additional
coins but they're the market leader and
they're the monopolist at this point
that's the way to do it so actually a
lot of that infrastructure is there
obviously more infrastructure is there
for Bitcoin of course but my point is
that you need to be decentralized
right because if you just just because
you have a decentralized store value
does it mean like if you then give it to
a lender or whatever if you then lend it
out in a centralized way you lose ninety
five percent of the benefits of it you
know you lose it east central you lose a
lot of privacy you lose a lot of the
censorship resistance so that's
important I think that's important up
the stack just like it is at the base so
from a theoretical perspective I agree
with you yeah yeah right there's two
points that come into play now do we go
from a centralized infrastructure around
Bitcoin and those companies can
decentralize over time maybe I don't
think we know that answer yet right and
there's plenty of people who will
pontificate on whether that's true or
not the bigger thing though is how much
of the defy infrastructure do you
actually think is decentralized yeah
that's a good question I don't know I
don't know the answer and I actually
don't even know if the answer is bad
answer for the SVT I just like how do
you even figure that out yeah right
because it can't be a hundred percent
but it's also not zero percent yeah
absolutely not no we need to become more
decentralized there's a lot of sort of
governance decentralization
infrastructure that has to happen on the
etherium community in d5 right now like
how do you make a doubt he centralized
autonomous organization work at scale
which which were calls work in a
decentralized way that's very difficult
yeah the big challenges the technical
risks like something like a dowel to me
if you can make it work in a secure
predictable way that people have
confidence in it would be massive it
would be incredible hmm it's just we got
a lot of work to do to get to and I
think that's you're saying the same
thing right if just like this stuff is
really really hard
totally it's not gonna happen overnight
and so that's why we need as many people
working on as we possibly can totally
but I do think there is
centralization at the beginning
significant I think mostly net so you're
building complex software and the more
complex it is the more you need like a
you know a corporation is the most
authoritarian and centralized that you
democracy or like of a public form of
government for a corporation would be
nonsensical like you need to have an
authoritarian top-down structure that's
at least somewhat hierarchical and you
know Silicon Valley is less hierarchical
whatever but I need to be pretty
hierarchical in order to ship fast and
have secure code and respond to customer
demands and so forth so I think you know
we've seen this trend where most of the
dphi projects they start pretty
centralized and their equity investments
and and you know they have corporations
or foundations that have sort of
hierarchical they're built they build
software the way that Microsoft builds
software and that's good because
Microsoft builds good software but over
time they will do centralized so
compound actually just released a token
or announced it released its token a few
weeks ago it's just to existing
shareholders like us compound is the
second biggest or so it's one of the
biggest decentralized finance projects
it's basically a money market on
aetherium it's actually one of the most
sophisticated probably working adapts
today and and yeah they just released a
token and so they're moving gradually
towards decentralization I think that's
great I mean there might be a period
where the company dissolves there might
be a period where the CEO is no longer
involved with it and that's possible
it's hard of course but this is a
community of decentralization and like
all things start I mean most things
start centralized and decentralized
Atocha very centralized the beginning of
course and then I mean even I like to
like look at George Washington you have
to have a moment where George Washington
leaves and sort of like gives it up to
other people but it's fine if it takes
eight years to get there right actually
that's probably the golden number if you
look historically of like how
democracies form which is a form of
political decentralization usually you
have a ruler that rules for like 10 20
years sometimes less like George Walsh
the first one is this guy sahlan of
Athens we don't have to talk about that
they all like institute democracies and
they rule for
10 years to make sure things go okay and
complex systems get adapted and
institutionalized then they peace you
know they leave the traveller world they
go in on mystic Satoshi I think that's
probably a good model it's like a 4000
year old model of decentralization it
probably applies here I've never heard
anyone describe it that way I love that
yeah